welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
Mandalorian recap before season three
including Mando scenes from book of Boba
Fett mandalorians are basically a
warrior Clan easily recognizable by
their super sweet Boba Fett armor our
main character has no name yet people
just call him Mando and like many other
mandalorians he is a bounty hunter he's
part of a bounty hunter Guild led by
Carl Weathers whose Star Wars name is
grief karga he's got a job Fernando that
pays real well but is a bit sketchy
because the client is ex-imperial the
show takes place soon after the original
trilogy when the evil empire has just
recently been defeated but many
Imperials are still out there holding on
to what power they can like this guy who
has a job from hando he won't tell him
anything about the mark But the pay is
very real not in Imperial credits but in
bescar steal a super strong medal from
the Mandalorian Homeworld Amanda takes
it down to the swords where apparently
he lives with a bunch of mandalorians
they're led by a female Mandalorian the
armorer and none of them ever take their
helmets off that's a part of their
strict code of conduct this is the way
this is the way she melts down the best
car into a sweet shoulder guard for him
and while she's forging we get Mando's
backstory basically his village was
attacked his parents died trying to save
him but he was eventually rescued by
mandalorians who adopted him into their
crew so Mando flies off to hunt his mark
on a super cool spaceship the razor
Crest Commando tracks down the mark but
there's another Bounty Hunter here a
Droid ig-11 who's got super sweet spinny
arms so they find the mark but turns out
it is a baby Yoda it's not the baby Yoda
it's a baby Yoda we don't know a species
name but whatever it is it is
aggressively cute the droid's just gonna
shoot it but Mando's not letting that
happen shoots him first and it's the
start of a beautiful friendship now
Mando parked a ship in a bad
neighborhood the Jawas have stripped it
for parts they want some egg from the
giant woolly rhinoceros he had a mud
horn that kicks Mando's butt in fact
he's about to die here but wait what's
this it's baby Yoda Force Powers oh he's
adorable together they take this thing
down but now he's all tuckered out he
trades the egg for ship parts back and
now they're headed home but baby Yoda is
such a cute little nuisance keeps
playing with his little stick shift the
client is very excited about baby Yoda
and pays him a whole bucket of best car
Amanda's like hey you're not going to
hurt this kid are you but the client's
like that's none of your business so
Mando lets him go he brings the best
guard to the armor who forges him a
complete set of best car steel armor
looking fly as hell man knows all
business on to the next job but when he
tries to shift gears sees the knobby
missing and it's like dang that kid's
too cute I can't leave him Mando busts
in there and saves baby Yoda from some
creepy science experiments he's gotta
fight a bunch of Stormtroopers with a
variety of weapons including his
flamethrower all right but now the words
out to all the bounty hunters to
recapture him so it's a standoff in the
street then a big shootout Amanda's way
outnumbered until what's this
Mandalorian reinforcements flying in on
Jetpack super sweet they cover his
Retreat so Mendo and baby Yoda are
reunited though he really needs to get a
car seat for this kid they fly to a
remote planet where they meet Kara Doon
a shock trooper in the Rebellion at an
all-around badass she and Mando fight at
first but you can't fight when baby Yoda
is drinking soup by the way baby Yoda is
an adorable little carnivore his
favorite food is frogs there's two quick
side missions one on Tatooine yeah from
the original Star Wars he goes to Moss
Eisley Cantina and fights an assassin in
the desert then he takes a job with the
old crew he used to run with who are
basically the evil Guardians of the
Galaxy eventually Mando gets a call from
Carl Weathers like hey buddy let's call
the truce that ex-impiro client has
taken over the town we need your help to
take him down Mendo thinks it's probably
a trap so he's bringing his new friends
as backup and it was gonna be a trap but
when baby Yoda saves group car goes live
he changes his mind he's now team baby
Yoda for life to get inside they pretend
to turn Mando into the client just then
though he gets a call from his boss and
oh those whole bars being shot up yes
it's a takeover from another ex-imperial
and this new villain is yes that's Gus
Fring from Breaking Bad it's moth Gideon
it's a big awesome fight scene but moth
Gideon cool as a cucumber blows Mando up
they Retreat back into the bar where
Kara Dunes okay let me take your helmet
off so I can heal you but he's like no a
Mandalorian never takes his helmet off
this is the way but IG 11's like yeah
I'm a Droid I'm pretty sure that's an
exception and so oh my God it's
happening it's Pedro Pascal's beautiful
face so he patches him right up and they
go down to the sores where the armor is
still hanging out she's like hey because
you saved to this kid according to
Mandalorian custom he's now officially
part of your Mandalorian gland she
engraves his armor with their new Clan
sigil the mud horn their first Victory
together she also gives him a jet pack
all right so they have to escape down
the ancient lava sword but there's one
more threat a TIE fighter driven by moff
Gideon so it's up to Mando and his new
jet pack baby
yeah flies up there grapples onto this
thing plants a bomb and pull
and put at the crashed TIE fighter moth
Gideon
and wait what is that it's an awesome
black lightsaber sword yes that's the
dark saber which are Star Wars nerd
friends will happily tell you all about
Greek cargo is like hey so three of us
restart the Bounty Hunter's Guild but
mandu's a father now he's not about that
bounty hunter life so he and baby Yoda
fly off into the sunset to have a whole
new season of Adventures in the
Mandalorian season 2 the main goal is to
get baby Yoda to safety with members of
his own kind but no one really knows who
that is so their Quest first takes back
to Tatooine where Amanda hurt there's
another Mandalorian here that could
maybe help him out and indeed there's a
dude here dressed like a Mandalorian
wearing Boba Fett's old armor but this
dude immediately takes his helmet off
which goes against the Mandalorian Creed
this is not the way this is Timothy
Oliphant who's the Marshal of this town
and he's no Mandalorian he just found
this cool armor Mando's like yo if you
aren't a Mandalorian you can't wear that
armor I'm taking it back but at the
moment they have a bigger problem it's a
crate Dragon unabsolutely massive sand
worm so Mando gets his first side quest
of the Season helped me kill that thing
and I'll give you this armor so it's
Plan B B strap some bombs to this bantha
and I'll get eaten but man don't makes
this thing spit him out then oh the
bombs boom exploded from the
from this Boba Fett's armor makes a new
friend we might see again later and
rides off into the sunset but watching
that Sunset is a mysterious figure and
it is the real bow buff that almost 40
Years of fan speculation could he have
survived the sarlacc bit he did in it
it's now Canon all right Amanda takes
another side quest to driving this frog
lady to get her eggs fertilized oh no
frog eggs baby Yoda don't eat those they
crash on a nice planet with tons of eggs
yes it's finally snacky time but oh no
these eggs are snacking back giant ice
spiders nope nope nope kill it with fire
Mando gets frog lady to her destination
but his Uber rating is gonna take a big
hit so Mando's search takes him to the
Seas where he's betrayed again but now
he's saved by the mandalorians he was
looking for who fly in and kick major
butt but they immediately take off their
helmets too come on where can a guy find
some real mandalorians but they're like
hey we're very real mandalorians like
actually from the planet Mandalore in
fact this is the rightful queen of
Mandalore Boca tan from the Clone Wars
animated series Star Wars super nerds
are freaking out and if you're not the
Star Wars super nerd don't be
intimidated by these other characters
showing up the Mandalorian stands on its
own as an awesome space adventure all
about Mando and baby Yoda now bocatan's
got some bad news for Mando the
mandalorians he was raised by are part
of kind of a crazy cult never taking
your helmet off is just their weird role
it's completely impressed tactical like
how do you eat but man those lived his
whole life by this rule he's keeping his
helmet on for now but he asks for their
help getting baby Yoda back to his
people apparently they're called the
Jedi booked hands like yeah I know where
a Jedi is but first I need your help
with the side quest her main goal is to
retake the Mandalorian Homeworld from
Imperial forces so now she wants Mando's
help hijacking an imperial weapon ship
but she's not just here for the cargo
she's also looking for someone the big
boss of the new Imperial forces our
show's main villain moff Gideon yes
remember he survived last season and has
a super cool glowing black sword the
darksaber turns out that sword belongs
to the ruler of Mandalore so she wants
it back but man does not sticking around
to help out with that he's gonna take
baby Yoda to a Jedi but first he makes a
pit stop to fix his ship with his old
friends Cara Dune and grief karga
naturally he gets roped into another
side quest per usual the mission goes
bad and it turns into an awesome action
sequence but wait what's this they got
things in tubes they were doing science
stuff here with the doctor that was
working on baby Yoda he doesn't fully
explain what they're doing but it sure
sounds like exactly what we assumed they
wanted to take the force powers from
baby Yoda and put it in moff Gideon so
Mando makes it to the planet with the
Jedi and Star Wars super nerds are
freaking out again because this is
Ahsoka Tano another big character from
The Clone Wars so she and Mando meet
didn't have a little fight but soon
she's like wait a second is that a baby
Yoda she's able to use the force to
communicate with him a little bit and we
don't get any answers on like what
species he is or is he Yoda's son or a
clone or just Sprout from an egg but we
do get some big news because this little
guy has a name it is grogu yeah I guess
it's good he has an official name it's
gonna take some getting used to though
I'm still gonna call him baby Yoda first
things first Mando's roped into another
side quest Ahsoka needs his help to save
this town while she goes in for a
samurai duel with the magistrate and she
fights with the spear made of beskar
steel which can yeah block lightsabers
in the end Ahsoka defeats her and she's
hunting down her boss Grand Admiral
thrawn yes another name dropped from
Star Wars rebels Star Wars super fans
going blah so watch out for that in
ahsoka's potential spin-off show but for
now back to baby grogu samando takes
grogu to the secret Jedi Rock which will
let him use the force to basically post
on the Jedi Facebook group but right now
someone else is flying in it's Boba Fett
who finally caught up to him and he's
not alone he brought a friend from
season one it's fenikshand yeah the
Assassin we fought on Tatooine she was
left for dead but Boba Fett saved her so
now she's loyal to him and has a robot
stomach he's like I'm not here to fight
I just want miyama back but they're
interrupted by Stormtroopers and have to
work together to fight him and Boba
Fett's in beast mode kicking ass with
nothing but his bathrobe and a stick but
soon he grabs his armor and Boba Fett is
back but up in orbit is MAF Gideon who
fires the big laser boom blows up
Mando's ship the razor Crest oh Geico's
not gonna cover that and now flying in
is a new class of droids the dark
Troopers and they grab little grogu no
baby Yoda's kidnapped so with Mando's
ship totaled it's like hey can I get a
ride and Boba Fett's like yeah bro I got
you that little baby Yoda is so cute
we're immediately bonded to him so for
the final mission they recruit Bo Katan
who's happy to help but remember MAF
Gideon and the dark saber are mine so
our crew bus sin pew pew pew this is a
stacked team who can take out basically
infinite Stormtroopers so our gang
easily takes the bridge but wait moff
Gideon's not here because he's with baby
Yoda who's in the tiniest little
handcuffs and so it's time for a dark
saber vscar steel spear oh yeah awesome
duel in the end of course Mando wins and
takes him off Gideon back to the bridge
where bocatan's like what have you done
turns out by sacred Mandalorian
tradition you can't just give the
darksaber away it has to be won in
combat so Mando just accidentally became
the rightful king of Mandalore and that
might cause some friction later but for
now they got bigger problems because the
dark Troopers are back and Our Gang is
cornered but who's this flying in in an
X-Wing yes someone responded to grogu's
Facebook post it is off
Jedi Master oh busting in there making
short work of these dark Troopers the
coolest Jedi scene yet and you know
there's only one guy this could be it is
the Luke Skywalker Star Wars super fans
blah he's gonna take baby Yoda off to
Jedi boarding school but first grogu's
gotta say goodbye to his papa Mando and
Amanda loves this kid so much he removes
his helmet and shows him his face oh
what a touching moment and so baby Yoda
grogu is finally safe Gonna Learn to use
his Force powers from the Luke Skywalker
but his bond with Mando runs deep you
know these two are gonna be reunited for
more adventures in season three now Boba
Fett got his own spin-off show the book
of Boba Fett he and fenixand took over
job of the Hutzel territory to become
the Crime Boss of Tatooine watch my
recap to get the full story in this
video we're going to focus on when Mando
shows up and he's not here for just a
cameo he takes over two full episodes
it's basically the Mandalorian season
2.5 he tracks down his old Mandalorian
Clan led by the armorer who survived but
it's just turn this one other dude now
she's impressed he has the legendary
dark saber Amanda's actually having
trouble using the darksaber it's weirdly
heavy for him and she's like you're
fighting against the blade whatever that
means but then there's a problem when
she's like by the way you ever take your
helmet off and he's like well I mean
yeah there were extenuating
circumstances though it was a baby Yoda
but in this Mandalorian cult there are
no exceptions for tender moments and
Mando is kicked out this is the way so
for now Amanda needs a new ship because
the razor Quest was destroyed last
season and his mechanic friends found a
beauty for him it is an old Naboo
Starfighter like from Star Wars episode
one now Mando goes to visit his son at
boarding school and yes we get to see
Luke Skywalker training little grogu and
pretty soon wow this guy's hopping
around yeah Mando can sell that stroller
but Mando doesn't get to see him he
stopped by the other Jedi asokatano
she's like hey man I know you love him
but to be a Jedi he's got to leave his
old life behind you come to visit him
it's just gonna make that harder and
it's heart-wrenching but Mando agrees
it's for the best and decides to leave
but when Luke hears about Mando's visit
he's like all right little girl who I'm
gonna give you a choice you can have
this super cute best car steel chainmail
and go be a Mandalorian with your papa
or you can stay here and be a Jedi with
Yoda's old lightsaber which you're gonna
have to grow into I guess but
unfortunately you can't have both
because that would be just way too cool
now Mando joins Boba Fett for his Show's
finale yes Mando and Boba Fett teaming
up two versus an army busting out their
full arsenal of weapons yes and in the
middle of this action who should show up
but baby Yoda who I guess hitchhikes
here yes little grogu made his choice he
wants to be with his papa Mando
unfortunately at the moment they're in
Mortal danger but it's little grogu who
steps in there proven he's the apex
predator the rancor is kinda just a big
frog he uses the force to calm this
thing down and now together they have a
little nappy time so Mando and baby Yoda
are reunited ready for more adventures
in the Mandalorian season 3.
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]